hey guys how's it going it's justine and
today we are talking about face id on
the iphone 10.
since i posted my unboxing video and my
top five features video one of the
biggest questions that i was getting is
about face id does it work can you wear
sunglasses can you wear a hat can you
wear a mask my sister
well i can't even tell you what she said
that she wanted to do to me basically it
involved removing my face and putting it
on her face but she got into some
graphic details
i'll spare those for you guys but to
answer your question
does face id work yes yes yes it does
and it works way better than i expected
it to work i'm so used to using the
surface studio
and sometimes it struggles to find you
it's like looking for you looking for
you like i'm right here
okay that was pretty quick surface
studio facial recognition success i
never had any facial recognition issues
on my note 8 or my essay but a lot of
people were freaking out about face id
because in the keynote there was an
issue
and this issue was misrepresented by
many people because they thought that
this was face id not working in the demo
when he went to unlock his phone
the phone had already been reset so
anytime you restart your phone you have
to enter a passcode and that's the same
for your current iphone right now if you
restart your phone it's going to make
you enter a passcode before you can use
touch id and what happened on stage was
that exact thing
i haven't run into a single issue in the
past few days i've been pretty impressed
with the angles at which you can unlock
your phone with face id i mean this is
pretty low i just have to like look up
and face id detects me like that's
that's really it
the first instance that i was like wow
this worked
really really well was i do my makeup in
the bathroom
and i had my phone just sitting on the
little vanity right by the sink
and i was kind of far away i was just
like it's probably not going to unlock
it's probably not going to see me
and i'm not i just looked over it's like
magic magic
another instance in my car i usually put
my phone
right here i use it for directions it's
basically like my navigation and it
hooks up to car play and sometimes your
phone will turn off i didn't want to
have to be distracted obviously if
you're in the car you should not be
texting or doing anything that will
distract you
with face id it was less intrusive than
doing touch id because before i would
kind of have to fumble around with it
trying to hit the touch id
and not knock it off of my dashboard the
face id it recognized me and i just
swiped up like that was that was it
there was there's no struggle there was
absolutely nothing i was afraid because
it was a little bit further than a
distance than when i had set it up that
it wouldn't recognize me but it did so
here's the demo
this is about how far this is kind of an
awkward shot because i'm trying to shoot
this myself okay it's locked now pay
very close attention
i just look tap swipe up it saw me
i think you guys get the point face id
is pretty great it's also extremely
intuitive because most the time you're
used to putting your finger here anyway
so it's almost like you're putting your
finger on touch id but you're just
swiping up and it just works it's just
it i just unlocked it super fast now the
first test that i want to do is with
sunglasses on
and they say that this should work no
matter what the pair of sunglasses on
but some sunglasses may have some sort
of protective coating that it can't
actually see your eyes
so that's a very important part when
using face id to make sure that it can
detect you
so let's see if they can detect me with
some of these sunglasses on i have a
pair of polarized ones
i have some fairly expensive sunglasses
i have some
very unexpensive sunglasses i have some
prescription sunglasses
let's see what happens so first thing
let's just look at it unlock there we go
magic the first pair of glasses that i
want to try are prescription ones
so here we go let's test this out and
see if it will
work i keep getting notifications
because it's almost time for hq trivia
if you guys haven't played hq trivia you
need to
hqtrivia.com this is not sponsored at
all but it is so fun twice a day they
are live they ask you trivia questions
and it's so much fun and you can win
real money but anyway moving on let's
test the glasses
okay there we go phone is locked oh gosh
hq trivia notifications and it just it
already automatically unlocked it's
unlocked so
these glasses check one pair down this
is a pair of diff sunglasses
let's try these okay wow i look good
it's confirmed that it's locked
unlocked unlocked with sunglasses stiff
sunglasses
worked your baby let's see how you hold
up confirmed
lock hq trivia troopy is about to start
and i'm gonna miss it okay ready
dior unlocked let's try these ones these
are probably one of my favorite ones
confirmed lock unlocked
okay so i think we get the point that
most of the sunglasses that i probably
would be wearing
will work let's try these ones these are
polarized
oh i can't see anything i can't even see
the monitor that i'm using to shoot with
polarized sunglasses freaked me out i'm
not sure if i'm a fan i hope that's in
focus because i can't see the screen
unlocked so i guess polarized sunglasses
work as well
confirm the lock unlocked okay
all right well i guess that test went
well what about wearing a mask there's
no way that it's really going to work
with the mask on because
using the precision mapping it's
basically making a 3d map of your face
and three most important things is your
eyes your nose and your mouth what if i
just
kind of like cut out of a piece of paper
my eyes my nose and my mouth and see if
it can recognize me
i'll try it i don't have anything else
to do i mean i do
i have like a million iphone videos to
edit
craft time so this is gonna be super
silly because i don't have any scissors
i have a knife somewhere of course i do
so my eyes are about right here okay
here we go
one eye hey justine what did you do this
weekend
so that's this is not working out very
well like how am i gonna unlock my phone
if i'm a superhero
i'm gonna be wearing a mask detect me
it's me it's me you're looking for
tell me that you know it's me
all right making a paper mask
a lot of your iphone
it doesn't matter if you put fresh ink
in a printer it's always low on ink this
is a very important photo you don't
understand i need this
i need this a test that is also highly
recommended is printing out a picture of
your face
can you fool face id with a picture of
your own face we're gonna find out what
if i put the face over top of my face
of course well now there's no paper
the hardest part of this video was
getting a printer to work you're taking
too long
i only got this printer because it was a
beautiful one
[Music]
it's working it's working voila
it took me longer to get this printer to
work than to shoot and edit this entire
video
timeline the missing piece of the puzzle
sorry my office is messy
let's see if we can do this okay so i'm
going to hold my phone up as you can
see and then we're going to make sure it
stays locked
look at my face look at it
i'll hold it from different angles i'm
going to try to swipe up
face id is not working
on a picture of my face i'm gonna swipe
up
it didn't work well you can't print out
a picture of your face and expect
to hack into someone's phone it's not
gonna work
another question is does it work in the
dark yes
it does that's pretty dark okay
can you see that confirmation of it
being locked
ready wait for it because it's gonna
happen
very fast unlocked
another thing that's been interesting is
i don't have all of my apps on this
phone yet so i've still been using my
eight periodically like when i have to
order post mates or use my hue lights or
my sonos or things that i haven't
actually set up yet because
basically as soon as i got this phone
i've been shooting and testing so i
haven't really had time to sort of log
in
and reset all of my home kit apps so
going back to the 8 it's so strange
because the phone feels
massive in your hand and it's crazy
because i haven't had a small phone in
so long so you do get used to that but
when you're using the phone it doesn't
feel any different because the screen
real estate is
actually larger than on the plus phones
let's try a hat okay well of course it's
gonna
work with a hat on like that's a dumb
question and unlocked
it'll also lock on five tries so if
you're trying to use a face five times
and it doesn't work it'll lock and make
you re-enter your passcode so someone
who is trying to enter your phone
trying to use their face when their face
isn't your
trying to use your face or they're
trying to use your face unlike your
phone it does lock after five tries so
they'll have to enter your passcode so
if you're trying to sneak up to somebody
and sneakily unlock their iphone it's
not gonna work there's another thing
that i'd recommend making sure this
turned on is attention aware features so
you can
click here and it'll require attention
for face id so basically what that means
is that your phone will recognize when
you're looking at it so if somebody is
trying to unlock your phone from the
side using your face they won't be able
to you need to be looking directly at it
i'm sure a bunch of future apps will be
using that so they don't know that
you're really using your phone so for
example safari if you're reading
something sometimes the phone will dim
because it thinks that you're not using
it because of inactivity but you're
actually looking right at it your phone
will know that you're looking at it
and it won't dim your screen or turn off
but all in all after having it for three
days
it is a really amazing device and i'm so
happy with
it and i know i'm the biggest iphone fan
girl ever but if there was something
wrong with this
i have no problem telling you guys but
it really is just
it's just awesome and i'm so happy with
it anyway thank you guys so much for
watching i have some more fun iphone 10
videos coming out very very shortly so i
hope you guys are enjoying them if
there's anything that you would like to
see me try and test leave those in the
comments below and if you're not
subscribed already just hit the
subscribe button and i will see you guys
in the next video
[Music]
you